as with any annual game franchise it's
hard not to compare call of duty black
ops cold war to last year's modern
warfare on the campaign side
cold war easily outstrips last year's
game showing that call of duty fares far
better when it
airs on the side of fantasy in zombies
cold war has a far more successful co-op
mode than modern warfare's spec ops
though it's still in need of some
balance tweaks multiplayer however is
where cold war struggles most it falls
flat and that's especially apparent in
warzone's shadow
because i already shared my thoughts
about the campaign at launch i won't go
on about it too much here
you can watch my campaign impressions
video or read my full review on gamespot
for more details about the campaign but
overall i had a ton of fun with it it's
goofy in places and kind of fumbles its
best ideas at the end but it
incorporates the spy
intrigue well and delivers a dramatized
fantastical version of the cold war that
is easy to get absorbed in so let's talk
about multiplayer
as with any call of duty game the
standard suite of 6v6 multiplayer modes
is here
there's not much to say about the modes
themselves that hasn't been said before
they're the bread and butter of the
multiplayer cod experience and most of
them work well
there's a relatively small group of maps
available currently with more already
announced the cold war setting allows
for a lot of variety from one map to the
next which helps the limited slate feel
richer a highlight in terms of aesthetic
is miami's neon soaked streets
each core 6v6 map balances close quarter
spaces with
long range sight lines and in my
experience they mostly translate well
from one mode to the next
combined arms is cold war's answer to
modern warfare's ground war and it's my
favorite of the multiplayer modes the
12v12 objective based mode incorporates
vehicles at a manageable scale you get
boats on armada motorcycles on cartel
and
snowmobiles and tanks on crossroads
armada is the standout map with several
ships connected by ziplines to get
around you can take the zip lines
swim or commandeer a speedboat or a
larger turreted vessel this provides a
lot of dimension to the map you can
attract the attention of the opposing
team with a loud vehicle but get to the
objective faster
or you can dive underwater to avoid
detection and sneak up on the deck of a
ship at the cost of speed
the other two combined arms maps aren't
quite as exciting though while the boats
and ziplines of armada give you an
efficient way of navigating a
water-based map
cartel has tighter spaces and a lot of
bumpy ground so its motorcycles don't
serve much of a purpose besides alerting
everyone to your position
the tanks on crossroads are good for
causing explosions but you can be just
as effective if not more so on foot
conversely cartel and crossroads work
fine as 6v6 maps without their vehicles
whereas armada is missing a lot of its
charm without its boats
and while the maps are altered for the
smaller player count armada still feels
too big
it's much harder to get in a firefight
without objectives to guide you
fire team dirty bomb another new mode
suffers under the weight of its large
player count
the 40 player mode isn't battle royale
but it borrows ideas from battle royale
games including dropping out of a plane
into a free-for-all against other teams
of four
however it lacks the stakes that make
battle royale exciting
you can respawn over and over again
after a short cooldown and the
objectives are scattered around the map
which means it's never quite clear which
one you should be moving toward and
where other teams might be moving in
relation to you
it's easy to get flanked by multiple
teams because you can't be sure where
they're likely to come from
and because the maps are a bit too small
for the number of players you get into
frustrating scuffles often
across the multiplayer modes cold war
feels a bit clumsier than modern warfare
and by extension warzone
it's missing key mechanics that modern
warfare and warzone have including
mounting weapons and switching a
weapon's fire rate which leaves cold war
at odds with the war zone ecosystem of
course cold war and modern warfare take
place in two different eras so it's not
fair to expect them to be identical but
the two systems are different enough
that it's noticeable
especially in the movement and gunplay
it's not that one is better than the
other but it's a jarring adjustment to
switch to warzone after all warzone is
still an active part of call of duty and
is even launchable from the cold war
menu
a highlight in both multiplayer and
zombies has to be the ps5's dual sense
controller
cold war utilizes the dual sense
controller's various features including
nuanced haptic feedback and the adaptive
triggers
when you're low on health you can feel
your heartbeat in your hands as it
thumps in your ears and flashes red on
the screen when switching weapons you
can feel the difference in ads speed
through the left trigger's level of
resistance
you can feel the difference in fire rate
depending on how snappy or not the right
trigger is and the intensity of the
vibration changes depending on the
firepower and recoil you're working with
i actually find myself trying a wider
variety of weapons that i might have in
previous games and the way they feel to
shoot plays a big part in the ones i'm
using most
it's at least nice that multiplayer
shares gun progression with zombies
which is my way of segwaying into
zombies now
thanks to the mystery boxes random
weapons zombies is a great place to try
out new guns and level them up so you
don't have to go into multiplayer at a
disadvantage with no attachments
unlocked
i've always liked zombies but this is
the first time in a while that i felt
like i
actually learned and improved after each
run a big part of that is the map design
d machine is just the right size with
enough room that everyone can kite their
own crowd of zombies but small enough
that it doesn't take ages to learn the
map basics or reach a downed teammate to
rescue them
it only took a handful of runs to figure
out which doors to unlock and win
how to get the power on and how to
unlock the pack-a-punch machine once we
found a rhythm for the opening rounds we
could just focus on getting better and
surviving longer
however while the learning curve is
manageable the difficulty curve could
use some tweaks
it ramps up rapidly after round 10 as
base weapons start to get less and less
effective
on top of upgrading weapons at the
pack-a-punch machine using points you
also have to upgrade their damage tier
separately using
salvage which drops from zombies at
random
salvage is very rare compared to points
so you'll end up packing a weapon twice
before
round 20 but unable to upgrade its
damage tier to match
your ability to do damage can stall out
as a result
there's also radioactive bosses that
join the normal zombie horde every few
rounds which exacerbates this issue
these bosses are really spongy they eat
a lot of bullets and they survive
between rounds
by round 20 we end up spending a good
amount of our points at ammo crates just
to keep up
because packing a weapon the third and
final time costs a whopping 30 000
points
it's difficult to save enough for the
final upgrade let alone survive
long enough without the damage boost
you'll get from it the bosses themselves
challenge you to coordinate with your
team though and we found some success by
kiting a lone zombie around the map
while we dealt with the bosses
delaying the start of a new round this
way isn't a new strategy for zombies of
course but it's still satisfying to
execute especially while dodging
radioactive projectiles and trading off
runs to the ammo crates
it's just that the boss rounds occur too
close together to give you and your team
room to breathe
the biggest issue plaguing zombies at
the moment though is a bevy of server
and matchmaking hiccups i spend 10 to 15
minutes just troubleshooting matchmaking
before my team and i can actually start
playing and it's not uncommon for one
person to randomly error out right as
the run is starting
i've experienced this both when
utilizing crossplay and when playing
with only ps5 players
we've also had both ps5 and xbox series
x players experience hard crashes that
completely shut off their systems
technical issues like these are
forgivable in the grand scheme
considering cold war is cross gen
on top of allowing crossplay and
launching in the middle of pandemic
still it's worth noting that there are
some issues to be ironed out it's
reasonable to expect
updates to cold war at a steady clip
weapons will be tweaked
issues will be patched and gameplay will
be balanced zombies has a strong
foundation and may very well be improved
further by potential updates
but the gap between multiplayer and the
warzone ecosystem is too wide to be
bridged by small tweaks
zombies is a good co-op time overall but
multiplayer falls flat
leaving the strong campaign to do most
of the heavy lifting
[Music]